So the way I like to think about it,
is there's three main families of
reinforcement learning algorithms.
So, the one that's most like
what we've talked about so
far is what we could call model based
reinforcement learning algorithm.
So, model based reinforcement learning
algorithms takes the state action reward
tupples that it gets, and
sends them to a model learner, which
learns the transitions and rewards.
Those transition and rewards,
once you've learned them,
you can put through an MDPSolver,
like we talked about,
which could be used to spit out a Q*,
a optimal value function.
And once you have the optimal
value function, you can use,
just by taking the argmax of the state
that you are in, you can choose which
action you should take in any given
state and that gives you the policy.
So it's still mapping the state action
reward sequence to policies, but
it's doing it by creating all these
intermediate values in between.
Cool, and
let me just add one more thing,
which is that the model learner
takes the history that it's seeing.
But it also takes its current estimate
of transition to rewards to produce
the new estimate of
the transition rewards.
So, this is how I want to kind of
represent the learning piece of
the sequence.
Does that make sense?
All right, so this is one type.
Now let me show you another type.
So, the second class of
reinforcement learning
algorithm that's
important to think about.
They're referred to as
value-function-based, or actually,
sometimes model-free.
So, the beginning and
the end of it are still the same.
We're taking sequences of state action
rewards and producing a policy and
we even have this Q* in between
that we generate the policy
from using the argmax.
But now, instead of feeding back
the transitions and rewards,
we're actually feeding back Q*, and we
have a direct value update equation that
takes state action reward that it just
experienced, the current estimate of Q*.
Actually, it's kind of more Q than Q*,
and uses that to generate a new Q,
which is then used to generate a policy.
Yeah.
So instead of explicitly building
a model and using it,
it just somehow directly learns the Q
values from state actions and rewards.
And then the third class of
reinforcement learning algorithms comes
from the idea that you can sometimes
actually take the policy itself and
feed that back to a policy update that
directly modifies the policy based on
the state action rewards
that you receive.
So, in some sense, this is much, much
more direct, but the learning problem is
very difficult because the kind of
feedback that you're getting about
the policy isn't really very useful for
directly modifying the policy.
So, here's these three models all
together so you can compare and
contrast.
You can see,
in some sense, they're getting simpler
as [LAUGH] we go down to policy search.
But you could also say that
the learning is more direct.
And as we go up this way, the learning
problems become more supervised
in the sense that you can imagine
learning to predict next dates and next
rewards from previous dates and previous
rewards to learn T/R pretty directly.
It's basically a supervised
learning problem.
You get to see what
the output's supposed to be.
Here, you don't quite get to see what
the output's supposed to be, but
you do get values that you can
imagine propagating backwards.
And here,
you get very little useful feedback,
in terms of how to change your
policy to make it better.
>> Wait, so, the way you put that
suggests that you should always do one.
Well, so, yeah, but
look at all the extra stuff
that you're doing in between.
So, in fact, different problems
have different trade offs,
as to whether or not which of
these is the best thing to do.
A lot of the research has been
focused on number two, and
that's what we're going to be diving
into, because in some ways it strikes
a nice balance between keeping
the computations relatively simple and
keeping the learning
updates relatively simple.
But there are plenty of cases
where you'd rather do one and
where you'd rather do three.
>> I look forward to you
convincing me that that's true.